la expectativa por la esperada
contraofensivo ucraniana va en aumento
pero mientras las fuerzas ucranianas
continúan sumando equipos y fortalecen
su defensa comunidades capaces de
combatir los drones usados por la
fuerzas rusas contra ciudades y puestos
claves de Ucrania Más bien son grupos de
fuego móviles que están equipados con
ametralladoras pesadas estos grupos se
ocuparán principalmente de aviones no
tripulados de reconocimiento y ataque y
las unidades mejor preparadas pueden
incluso luchar contra misiles cruceros
pero los ataques rusos de los últimos
días han sido constantes causando bajas
entre civiles y militares anticipándose
a fuertes enfrentamientos en territorio
ucraniano las autoridades del país han
comenzado a evacuar a la población más
vulnerable de algunas ciudades
los bombardeos son intensos soy mayor y
para mí es difícil pasar por eso
me siento mal he tenido una vida larga
tengo 83 años y ahora tengo que irme de
Mi ciudad natal
pero al sur La Esperanza es la
motivación de los lugareños En nikolife
diversas unidades trabajan
cuidadosamente en el destinado de los
campos luego de La retirada de las
tropas rusas